bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat alors que le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel s'apprête à nommer un
nouveau président à la tête de france
télévisions
la commission de la culture ici au sénat
a décidé de mener une vaste série
d'auditions sur l'avenir du groupe
public
son modèle économique ses valeurs son
projet stratégique
parmi ces auditions est bien celle de
rémy pfimlin le président actuel du
groupe de télévision publique
je propose de la revoir aujourd'hui
parmi les thèmes abordés dans le
numérique
la multiplication des écrans le
rapprochement des rédactions ou encore
le mode de financement de l'audiovisuel
public
une audition pour voir les perspectives
du groupe de télévision mais aussi en
filigrane est bien pour faire le bilan
de rémy pflimlin à la tête de france
télévisions dans une atmosphère vous
allez le voir plutôt respectueuse tout
de suite direction la salle clemenceau
pour votre audition
nous poursuivons cet après midi nos
travaux sur l'avenir de france
télévision je vous rappelle ce que nous
avons dit ce matin l'année 2015 et d'une
année d'échéance selanne et aussi du
bilan qu'adrienne al que le législateur
a demandé au csa
c'est forcément forcément une année de
mise en perspective et de réflexion pour
le parlement la loi de finances 2015 a
été je vous le rappelle l'occasion pour
nous et notre rapporteur jean-pierre
leleux de se poser la question également
du financement de france télévisions de
l'audiovisuel public nous avons pour ce
faire monsieur le président en gage est
d'ores et déjà des travaux en lien avec
la commission des finances une mission
d'information et de contrôle sur le
financement de france télévisions à
l'audiovisuel public plus généralement
et son évolution
bien entendu nous nous posons aussi un
certain nombre de questions
nous sommes dans une période mouvante
désormais
on l'a vu ce matin l'audiovisuel public
français doit s'inscrire dans un cadre
plus large qui à la fois le cadre
européen et la mondialisation dont nous
interrogeons sur l'émission la
trajectoire de l'entreprise publique son
avenir les évolutions possibles et nous
voulions partager ce moment avec vous
pour que vous même vous puissiez nous
donner votre point de vue sur l'ensemble
de de ses sujets et qu'on puisse bien
sûr vous poser un certain nombre de
questions voilà je vous souhaite de sans
plus tarder la parole merci madame la
présidente
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs merci
beaucoup de m'accueillir je à votre
demande madame la présidente je ferai un
exposé liminaire d'une dizaine de
minutes pour pouvoir répondre à vos à
vos questions vous dire que je suis
heureux de pouvoir débattre avec vous de
ces questions fondamentales de l'avenir
du service public et que ça se passe
dans le prolongement des rapports que
votre assemblée a pu produire je pense
en particulier aux rapports récents de
monsieur lehoux rapport de monsieur
plancade sur les questions de relations
producteurs diffuseurs
la question de fond que vous posez dans
vos débats j'ai le sentiment est qu'ils
aient vraiment la question à laquelle
nous devons répondre aujourd'hui c'est à
quoi sert l'audiovisuel public dans un
univers qui change à grande vitesse et
qui a changé de façon absolument
incroyable au cours des cinq dernières
années et cette question elle est
évidemment légitime parce que nous
étions dans un univers extrêmement
limités en termes d'offre et qui était
relativement statique et à cette
question je réponds l'audiovisuel public
est plus nécessaire que jamais et c'est
une conviction profonde est plus
nécessaire que jamais pourquoi parce que
c'est une question d'abord de cohésion
nationale et les événements que nous
venons de vie
vivre dans ce mois de janvier sont des
événements qui montrent que notre
population française que nos concitoyens
ont besoin de lien de référence de
référence à leurs valeurs communes et
que ça ça passe nécessairement par un
lieu d'expression qui est aujourd'hui le
duel public que c'est une question aussi
d'indépendance du pays par rapport à ce
qui se développe les industries
américaines les fameux gaffe à google
apple facebook qui aujourd'hui en terme
de contenu de production de contenus et
de diffusion de contenus sont capables
d'avoir une empreinte très forte sur le
pays et cette question d'indépendance en
termes de création en termes de
construction d'imaginaire collectif est
évidemment fondamental
et puis pour une raison démocratique
c'est que pour que l'information
souhaitent une information de référence
il faut c'est une information dans
laquelle on investisse une information
qu'ils puissent travailler en toute
indépendance et sous toutes ses formes
et on sait bien que l'information n'est
pas aujourd'hui un lieu de rentabilité
et donc s'il n'y a pas un moment donné
une volonté publique
évidemment cette développement de
l'information indépendante ne
fonctionnera pas alors une fois que je
te dis cela c'est une affirmation une
conviction très profonde
c'est comment arrive-t-on à ce résultat
dans cet univers-là alors on y arrive
d'abord et pour moi c'est fondamental en
étant fidèle aux valeurs et ces valeurs
sont des valeurs qui sont évidemment
centrale aujourd'hui c'est des valeurs
d'universalité on doit pouvoir
s'adresser à tous les publics
on doit pouvoir être le reflet de la
diversité des opinions de la diversité
des origines je vous ai parlé de
l'indépendance il doit y avoir une
transparence totale et il doit y avoir
un travail de qualité d'innovation alors
dans un exposé liminaire je ne
détaillerai pas tout cela mais mais ces
questions là sont des questions
extrêmement importantes qui doivent
aujourd'hui nous permettre de faire la
différence et surtout d'être le
fondement du pacte entre l'audiovisuel
public et nos concitoyens
ce pacte est en fondé sur la confiance
et cette confiance c'est un moment donné
la crédibilité de ce lien entre les
différentes parties de la population qui
sont importantes
la deuxième chose derrière la fidélité
aux valeurs c'est la permanence aux
grandes missions
alors ces grandes missions sais je vous
le rappelle
informer éduquer divertir alors
évidemment informés et éduqués divertir
ça ne peut pas avoir le même sens en
2015 et dans les années à venir que ça
ne l'avait au moment où la télévision
publique se diffusait sur des canaux qui
étaient des canaux unique et exclusif
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui nous devons
revisiter ces éléments là les revisiter
en continuant à privilégier la création
et je vous rappelle de ce point de vue
là que nous jouons gros un rôle
fondamental puisque 60% de la création
dans ce pays est financé par le service
public que sur la question de l'offre
culturelle de l' offre différenciante en
termes de magazines en termes de
documentaires en terme de spectacle
vivant
nous devons continuer à pouvoir jouer ce
rôle extrêmement important qui est un
rôle qui nous permet un moment donné à
partir de ce qu'ils sont nos valeurs nos
racines notre histoire de créer encore
une fois ce ce lien la question de la
proximité la question la présence sur
les territoires territoire qui par
ailleurs que ce soit en métropole ou en
outre-mer sont des territoires dans
lesquels les médias traditionnels ont du
mal à se développer nous avons
évidemment un rôle fondamental à jouer
enfin concernant l'information la
présence non seulement sur les
territoires mais aussi du point de vue
national d' équipe qui non seulement
nous permettre d'avoir une information
mais aussi de développer des magazines
des enquêtes et toute une série de deux
lieux d'expression de l'information me
semble tout à fait fondamental
évidemment
pour ce faire nous sommes là sur les
objectifs en termes de contenu et les
objectifs sociaux
l'entreprise doit se transformer alors
elle se transforme de façon considérable
et et je voudrais sur ce point
simplement madame la présidente puisque
vous parlez de deux des quatre années
qui viennent de se passer dire combien
pendant ces quatre années
l'entreprise s'est profondément
transformée elle s'est profondément
transformé d'abord parce que elle a
basculé dans le numérique le numérique
faut que vous sachiez que lorsque et en
2010 comme en cette période de quatre
ans le numérique en est à ses
balbutiements
nous lançons à l'époque la télévision de
rattrapage la télévision de rattrapage
de la première année en 2011
c'était 60 millions de vidéos vues dans
l'année
ce mois de janvier nous avons fait ce
sens soit nous avons eu 170 millions de
vidéos vues dans le mois ce qui veut
dire que nous allons pendant cette année
2015 dépasser le milliard 500 millions
de vidéos vues en rattrapage je pourrais
parler des plates formes que ce soit la
plateforme information sport éducation
culture culturebox qui aujourd'hui
connaît un essor considérable et bien
sûr l'arrivée dès réseaux sociaux nous
sommes donc aujourd'hui dans un univers
qui est en train de totalement changer
de paradigme de façon de fonctionner et
nous devons non seulement nous adapter
en termes de diffusion de contenus sur
ces univers pourquoi parce que si
l'audiovisuel public constitue le lien
entre nos compatriotes
alors nous devons être présents sur les
écrans que consulte nos compatriotes et
être présent sur ses écrans ça veut dire
être non seulement en termes de capacité
de consultation mais aussi de dialogue
de capacité à créer du lien et et à nous
développer
deuxième élément important de cette
période derrière le numérique c'est la
fusion de toutes les entreprises et la
constitution de la nouvelle entreprise
alors cette nouvelle entreprise c'était
un travail considérable de
transformation qui s'est accompagnée
d'un travail d'économies important
je vous rappelle que en 2011 nous avons
signé un contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens que ce contrat d'objectif et
moyens a été renégocié un an après en
2012 et qu'en 2012 cette renégociation a
donné lui à 300 millions d'économies
ce plan d'économies extrêmement
important est un plan qui d'abord est
respecté et respecter ça veut dire que
sur toutes les lignes d'économies sur
lesquels nous étions engagés et on peut
les détailler mais tous les documents
sont évidemment à votre disposition les
plans d'économies ont été engagées en
particulier sur des aspects tout à fait
important qui sont tout ce qui est lié
aux frais généraux frais centraux à tout
ce qui est la puissance d'achat mais
aussi sur les productions avec d audit
systématique et des baisses de coûts de
programmes et de production extrêmement
important et puis de façon interne nous
avons pendant cette période négocier un
nouveau contrat d'entreprise qui est le
nouveau contrat qui régit la vie des
salariés dans l'entreprise
ce contrat d'entreprise a notamment
traité des questions extrêmement
importantes comme le temps de travail
sur la question du temps de travail nous
avons en particulier intégrer la notion
de forfait jours j'ai vu la semaine
dernière qu'une grande entreprise
publique s'appelle et df commencé à
traiter le sujet ce sujet a été traité à
france télévisions
de même qu'a été traités à france
télévisions la question des automatismes
salariaux qui vous le savez prend une
grande partie des augmentations salaires
possible et je vois qu'une autre grande
entreprise publique la sncf commencent
aussi à un traité le sujet donc nous
avons là des sujets extrêmement
important dans la vie de l'entreprise
dans la manière dont cette entreprise
peut affronter les éléments de
changement que nous sommes en train de
mettre en place
même chose pour les rédactions puisque
nous avons lancé le programme de
rapprochement des rédactions qui s'est
traduite façon concrète à partir du mois
d'avril dernier par la construction d'un
pc info c'est à dire le lieu unique de
centralisation des éléments
constitutifs de nos journaux
d'informations numérisées qui sont au
même endroit et à partir doit partir
duquel on est dit donc des
transformations importantes qui sont en
lieu en actuellement en mouvement et qui
nous permettent d'aborder le futur en se
disant que nous devons continuer à faire
des gains de productivité
ces gains de productivité étant
l'efficience de la maison et cette
efficience elle est extrêmement
importante parce que c'est la manière
pour nous de dire à d'abord
représentants de nos concitoyens que
vous êtes maître plus généralement à
l'ensemble du peuple français
l'argent que vous nous confiez nous en
faisons le meilleur usage pour autant il
faut absolument que cette vision de
l'efficacité économique s'inscrivent
dans une perspective qui soit une
perspective claire en termes de
financement et pérenne il n'est pas
possible et je le dis ici solennellement
que nous continuons à voir les missions
extrêmement importantes que nous avons
en termes de création en termes
d'information en termes de présence sur
le territoire en terme de développement
de l'innovation numérique et de ne pas
avoir une vision du financement de
l'entreprise
or cette fragilité du financement
aujourd'hui est évidemment extrêmement
perturbantes non seulement pour le
développement de l'entreprise mais aussi
pour simplement la mise en oeuvre des
process liés à ses fonctions et ses
missions si vous vous lancez dans la
création
vous êtes sur des processus de plusieurs
années une fiction un film de cinéma un
grand documentaire vous le lancez pour
d'ici deux ans pour certains perd
certaines oeuvres
nous venons de faire pendant trois
semaines des grands documentaire de
william karel sur la destruction des
juifs d'europe sais pas si certains
d'entre vous eu l'occasion de le voir
c'était une oeuvre majeure qui expliquer
ce qui s'est passé
c'était trois ans et demi de travail je
pourrais multiplier les exemples de ce
type là donc contrairement à une
entreprise privée qui peut à un moment
donné adapté
ses moyens ses dépenses à ses moyens
nous avons aujourd'hui des missions et
pour remplir ses missions
nous devons dans une perspective claire
donc la pérennité du financement est
absolument fondamentale et la deuxième
chose c'est que il faut que cette
entreprise qui est aujourd'hui se
réforme de façon importante et bien
elles puissent avoir un travail dans la
longueur et dans le prolongement les
réformes qui se succèdent aux réformes
les réformes qui succède aux
contre-réformes sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement pénalisante pour
l'entreprise et et nous avons
aujourd'hui la nécessité d'avoir par
rapport aux anneaux personnel et par
rapport à nos missions
un cadre qui sont un cadre qui permette
et dans le terme du financement est dans
la question des missions de la pérennité
voilà ma présidence je crois que j'ai
pris mes dix minutes j'ai été
nécessairement superficiel mais j'ai
obéi aux instructions
ça facilitera immédiatement les échanges
et les questions qui vous êtes
on vous êtes posé mes chers collègues je
vous rappelle les délais sont venus de
cet après midi donc si vous pouviez être
le plus concis et précis possible non
dans vos questions je dois tout de suite
la parole à notre rapporteur jean-pierre
leleux et après j'ai déjà deux demandes
de prise de parole bien merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président en
quelques mots et quelques questions bien
que nous connaissons bien la situation
actuelle qui est assez mouvementée à la
fois sur l'évolution des modes de
fonctionnement et des dispositifs que
nous connaissons bien
vous arrivez dans un contexte aussi
assez particulier non pas uniquement
parce que le mandat de président est en
cours de remise en cause par le csa avec
les difficultés que ça représente mais
aussi je veux dire et je pense que
certains orateurs reviendrait dont vous
arrivez après une émission de france 3
qui nous a tous fait très très plaisir
et vous devez vous attendre à quelques
questions sur le sujet
moi je voudrais revenir à la notion
d'indépendance de l'audiovisuel public
car je crois qu'elle n'existe pas et je
voudrais vous demander quels seraient
les réelles mesures à prendre pour que
cela soit je pense que l'actionnaire qui
est l'état intervient extrêmement
régulièrement dans le fonctionnement et
vous êtes dépendant en permanence de
choix budgétaires de choix de partage
d'année en année qui font que on a
vraiment un doute sur la capacité d'un
patron de france télévisions d'aller
dans sa stratégie avec son conseil je
pense que c'est difficile aujourd'hui de
le faire deuxièmement est-ce que vous
pensez que nos méthodes actuelles
permettent peut-être pas le moment de le
dire mais d'agir dans la durée
vous vous lavez vous l'avez souligné
mais nous je pense qu'il faut mettre en
place aussi des mesures qu'il faut que
quand une stratégie est adoptée elle
soit maintenu et qu'un cap soit pérenne
quelque part et là on a l'impression
d'un mondial de bord vers des objectifs
souhaités mais ne connais un peu de mal
atteint je voudrais revenir sur la
publicité vous avez souhaité exprimer le
souhait d'augmenter vos plages
publicitaires pour améliorer le
financement et on comprend que c'est
presque une piste obligatoire mais
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est bien
voilà est-ce que vous pensez que dans le
cadre d'une différenciation de la
couleur du service public dans le
paysage global est ce que
vous n'êtes pas là un peu quand même
l'objet d'une d'une schizophrénie entre
la recherche éventuelle d'un audimat
favorable pour financer pour avoir des
revenus publicitaires adaptés à cette
audi maths et l'autre missions qui sont
les objectifs de service public que le
cahier des charges où le contrat
d'objectifs et de moyens impose
voilà les quelques questions dont on a
déjà eu que le l'occasion de partager
les sujets sur lesquels j'aimerais avoir
votre éclairage
merci monsieur le rapporteur je vous
êtes mis devant la parole est ensuite on
prendra
ils demandent des orateurs merci madame
monsieur le rapporteur peut-être
rapidement puisque vous avez évoqué en
début l'émission de france 3 sur
laquelle j'ai eu des entretiens que le
président larcher et puis j'ai pu voir
d'ailleurs sur mon antennes de france 3
le lendemain de l'émission la séance en
direct à l'assemblée vous dire que
c'était une émission qui fait partie de
nos émissions de dents kate et
d'investigations nous en avons plusieurs
qui a appris un angle qui était un angle
sur effectivement l'utilisation des
fonds c'est un angle parmi d'autres
c'est en tout cas les deux clés deux
choses que je voudrais dire c'est que la
question des questions qui ont été
abordées s'inscrivent dans un débat et
je les dis au président larcher qui
n'est pas clos et ce débat doit se
poursuivre aussi un débat public par
ailleurs et je sais qu'il ya énormément
de mesures qui sont prises et qui
pourront être décrite est expliqué
d'autre part ça ne résume pas et de loin
pas la manière dont les travaux du sénat
sont relayés sur nos antennes et j'en
veux pour seule preuve le fait que en
direct toutes les semaines il y à la
relation d'aidé des travaux du sénat que
nous avons aussi par ailleurs toute une
série de reportages sur nos antennes qui
parle du du sénat comme il parle de
l'assemblée nationale
concernant la question de l'indépendance
elle est évidemment centrale
c'est à dire que la question de
l'indépendance elle est le coeur de la
relation de confiance avec nos
concitoyens
s'il n'ya pas independancia pas
confiance et cette indépendance elle ne
peut être fondée et c'est le premier
point que sur un financement pérenne et
indépendant et ça c'est à l'image de ce
que font notamment les allemands les
anglais où tous les pays du nord 7
un financement qui est un financement
qui à un moment donné inscrit dans un
cadre et ce cadre est un cadre
intangible et donc j'en viens à votre
point concernant la publicité à partir
du moment où ce cadre est intangible
il y a nécessairement de la part de
l'entreprise la possibilité de
développer une action et de la
développer dans un contrat d'objectif
puisque cet objectif est fixé par par
l'actionnaire c'est à dire par le pays
mais dans ce cadre là avec des grands
objectifs la conduite de l'entreprise
est évidemment totalement indépendante
et ne peut pas être remise en cause
comme elle est trop remise en cause dans
ce pays et les remises en cause pour les
raisons mais sur la porter vous avez
évoqué c'est à dire tous les six mois un
budget notamment depuis que la publicité
est arrêté après après 20 heures
cette ligne budgétaire qui vous
rappellent 420 millions et qui est passé
à 100 maintenant fait qu'on nous sommes
dans des incertitudes qu'il faut lever
alors pour l'élever il n'ya que deux
solutions la première c'est qu'il faut
supprimer la ligne budgétaire et ça
c'est la décision du gouvernement que je
salue il faut qu'on ait une redevance ou
une contribution qui soit une
contribution pérenne et dynamique
c'est à dire il faut que son assiette
évolué le président de la république a
indiqué qu'il souhaitait que cela se
fasse et je crois que c'est
indispensable comme l'ont fait tous nos
pays voisins notamment tous les pays
anglo saxons
et puis concernant la publicité il faut
qu'à un moment donné dans la perspective
des missions et des besoins de
financement mais on cale le besoin
publicitaires aux besoins de financement
la différence entre le privé et le
public publicité ou pas publicité est
évident d'ailleurs je crois que vous
avez examiné ce matin dans vos débuts de
vos travaux l'étude harris qui a
notamment été demandée par télérama qui
dit que le public ne s'y trompe pas et
dickens différence entre le privé et le
public si je crois que la première des
choses que dit l'étude harris et il s'y
trompa et ce n'est une des grandes
différences si nous avons de la
publicité
c'est par exemple nous ne mettons pas de
la publicité dans les programmes c'est
une différence majeure pour nos
concitoyens
et puis nos missions nous les
remplissons mais il est d'une certaine
manière le fait que nous n'ayons de la
publicité que l'après-midi veut dire
pour aller dans votre sens monsieur le
rapporteur que nous devons maximiser les
audiences commercial l'après midi et que
si nous avions par exemple de la
publicité en soirée
la pression serait moins fort sur
l'après midi voilà un exemple un minot
de cela étant il nous faut un
financement pérenne et il nous faut un
financement au service d'objectifs très
clair et différents objectifs du du
privé alors ce que je pense si vous
voulez c'est que pour agir dans la durée
il nous faut non seulement un cadre
financier très précis mais il nous faut
des objectifs stratégiques et politique
au sens noble du terme qui soit
probablement plus concentré et plus
précisément stratégique que la
multiplication de petits objectifs nous
avons nous avons là cahier des charges
qui fait plus de 70 pages
nous avons dans le contrat d'objectifs
et de moyens 70 objectif numéro deux qui
sont numérotées qu'il faut atteindre
enfin si mais ya un faisceau de
contraintes qui fait qu' évidemment
la capacité notamment s'adapter la
capacité d'être plus plus souple et plus
mobile et est entravée mais je crois que
la manière dont aujourd'hui le
gouvernement veut aborder les choses
notamment à travers le rapport qui a été
commandé à marc schwartz va dans ce sens
merci monsieur le président monsieur
retailleau avait demandé en premier la
parole
assouline oui monsieur le président je
voudrais simplement revenir sur cette
fameuse émission pas pour polémiquer
mais pour poser un certain nombre de
questions parce que je pense que c'est
suffisamment rare que le président du
sénat écrivent au président directeur
général c'est ce public que du visuel en
france pour que l'on s'y attarde justin
justin moment
ce qui est choquant ça n'est pas du tout
que senna soit critiquée et si le sénat
est critiquable il n'a qu'à s'en prendre
qu'à lui et à se réformer profondément
si le président du sénat vous a écrit ça
n'est pas pour protester contre
l'orientation d'une émission qui
souhaitent critiqué le sénat encore une
fois les journalistes sont absolument
libre et j'admets parfaitement cure
france télévisions et puisse y avoir des
émissions qui prennent pour cible des
institutions de la république
je pense que notre président vous
interpeller sur la méthode de cette
émission
approuvez vous monsieur le président
kuhn identités soit falsifiés pour que
un journaliste qui n'est pas de françois
s'en réclament
approuvez vous monsieur le président que
un synopsis soit adressée aux services
du sénat qu'ils soient truquées
mensonger approuvez vous monsieur le
président que pour une émission de
service public on puisse violer un
domicile privé
enfin approuvez-vous la méthode de la
caméra cachée pour pied chez un certain
nombre de collaborateurs du sénat en
d'autres termes ces méthodes s'agit
encore une fois je ne veux pas me
prononcer sur la critique ou non notre
institution
s'il ya des critiques c'est à nous d'y
répondre mais une fois de plus les
méthodes que je viens d'énoncer les
revendiquez-vous qu'aux méthodes
légitime du service public
monsieur tout le monde se film là et si
je me serais parle de monsieur prix je
réponds non pardon alors sauté aux yeux
très très très simplement je suis
directeur de la publication
je suis responsable des contenus donc
j'assume tous tous les contenus et c'est
ma responsabilité n'a que les choses
soient extrêmement clair là dessus c'est
ma responsabilité
le nous sommes dans le cadre d'une
émission d'investigation
cette émission d'investigation elle ne
prend pas pour cible
je reprends ce terme là elle ne prend
pas pour cible le l'objectif de cette
émission n'est pas de prendre pour cible
elle a des angles une émission
d'investigation qui a des envies on a
des missions d'investigation sur toutes
nos chaînes et qui d'ailleurs on parle
d'indépendance sont perçues par le
public comme étant la marque de
l'indépendance du service public il faut
que vous le sachiez et de façon
extrêmement importante je pense à
complément d'enquêté je pense à kamke
enfin je pense à toute une série cash
investigations etc
alors après qu' il ya un projet et que
ce projet je vais pas détailler les
choses mais que dans ce projet il ya
aujourd'hui de l'acquisition
d'informations suivant certaines
certaines choses on peut discuter dans
le détail mais encore une fois il n'ya
pas
deux projets qui visent à dire je prend
pour cible ça je relève ce point la
deuxième chose c'est qu'à un moment
donné il ya une émission qui ouvre un
débat qui s'inscrit dans un débat sur le
visage de l'argent public qui existe
d'ailleurs au delà de ce que nous avons
fait puisque non mais vous voyez et dans
ce cadre là et dans ce cadre là
eh ben il ya une émission et le débat
n'est pas clos le débat se poursuivre
oui oui monsieur le président cette
audition a est importante et je ne
voudrais pas face au lot france à
l'audition et à notre institution en la
portant sur une émission qui nous
concerne qu on apprécie ou pas c'est pas
l'objet de cette audition qui est de
s'interroger sur le service public et
donc je voudrais par ce prêt ce propos
préalable remettre sur les rails
qu'a voulu la présidente en proposant
cette journée sur l'avenir du service
public de télévision que l'on parle des
enjeux pour notre pays et parle le telle
ou telle critique ou même méthode de
critiques sur le sénat où chacun a pu
s'exprimer pour encore s'exprimer deux
donc c'est un propos préalable de le
on a souvent échangé sur ces questions
avec monsieur legendre j'avais produit
un rapport de bilan de l'application de
la loi sur le service public audiovisuel
beaucoup de choses ont été faites je
veux une fois n'est pas coutume dire que
quel que soit tout ce qu'il faudra
probablement changer bouger muté dans
l'audiovisuel public pour qu'il prenne
toute sa mesure
il faut rendre hommage à détournant le
tournant numérique a été pris avec force
il donne des résultats vous avez donné
des chiffres probablement il doit
prendre encore une nouvelle dimension
il ya des émissions de très grande
qualité qu'on ne retrouve nulle part
ailleurs pour lé raison vous avez dit il
ya des moyens et du temps donné
notamment cette série sur la destruction
des juifs d'europe est particulièrement
remarquable il y a une il y en a eu
d'autres de ce type historique qui
éduque qui donne de la profondeur et
c'est dans le service public on le
trouve à je veux ensuite vous connaissez
en jeu et je vous en ai déjà fait part
on que faisons nous pour endiguer
quelque chose qui est mortelle à terme
pour le service public le rajeunissement
de son audience ne peut pas rester sur
ce vieillissement là parce que y compris
le lien entre le public qui est presque
en actionnariat populaire par la
redevance qui devient la recette
principale pourrait bien et qui peut
être pérenne si on l'a sécurisé donc
tout citoyen contribue et 6
la frange centrale population active et
jeunes n'est pas dans l'audience
principal de france télévisions il ya
une déconnexion qui s'est vu que la
concurrence est très lourde et très
grande
quelque chose qui fait péricliter donc
rajeunissement
que pensez vous après que le sénat y
contribuer à ce débat notamment dans la
loi pour qui aller dans le sens d'un de
vos souhaits qui était de faire en sorte
et c'est aussi une réponse financière
comme on finance que quand vous
investissez dans la production
il y aller retour plus grand que
aujourd'hui il ya un décret après donc
presque un an de négociations que pensez
vous est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
ce qu'il faut ouvrir un deuxième
discussion parce que c'est
insatisfaisant ou au milieu du gué ou
est-ce que vous pensez que des progrès
ont été faits qu'on que ça va dans le
bon sens donc deuxième question est la
dernière je sais que à biarritz
l'occasion d'un débat avec vous de le
dire je le dis maintenant un peu partout
parce que c'est un enjeu on est à une
croisée des chemins avec dans les trois
mois qui viennent sur les projets et
l'avenir de france télévision
l'impératif à travers y compris ce qui
s'est passé dans notre pays et
l'importance que revêt lé informations
je le disais ce matin
pas seulement l'information mais ça en
analyse critique son analyse historique
son regard sa hiérarchisation
tout cela prend une importance forte
notamment quand on se rend compte que
les thèses complotistes c'est à dire
qu'il ne crois rien de ce qui est dit à
la télévision
en déconstruisant sur la base de
n'importe quoi tout parce que bon
comment faire en sorte que france
télévisions qui ait les moyens sur le
terrain dans chaque région avec france 3
jusqu'au meilleur reporter international
donc une force de frappe journalistique
et de qualité énorme
comment faire que ce soit france
télévisions qui donne le la de
l'information dans notre pays avec ses
prérogatives et ses missions d'éducation
alors qu'aujourd'hui ces données
autrement et notamment par les chaînes
d'info en continu privés qui n'ont pas
ces missions de service public qui nous
pas donc le même niveau exigé de
responsabilité d'intérêt général voilà
les questions merci monsieur assouline
avant de passer la parole à d'autres
collègues je voulais quand même vous
rappeler pour réagir aux propos vous
avez tenu en début de votre discours
je n'ai pas besoin d'être rappelés à
l'ordre sur la façon de gérer le temps
de parole est l'expression libre
d'expression est libre au sein de nos
commissions de l'ensemble de nos
collègues je voulais quand même faire
cette précision
c'est l'état d'esprit de la commission
madame galli oui madame la présidente je
voulais revenir un peu sur ce que
d'ailleurs on avait un peu dit ce matin
finalement c'était une bonne préparation
à 7 à cette audition de cette après midi
puisque vous on a parlé de la publicité
et vous dites
après 20 heures effectivement il ya
publicité n'y est pas je pense c'est une
erreur parce que de toute manière
aujourd'hui quand même on a l'air dans
les chaînes privées la publicité yéyé je
dirais très très fortement donc je pense
que un peu plus un peu de publicité à
france télévisions ne ferait pas de mal
et je vois pas aujourd'hui les
téléspectateurs sans s'inquiéter on s'en
émouvoir puisque il ne les empêche pas
d'aller sur les chaînes privées alors
qu'ils sont abreuvés
de publicité croyez-moi entre presque
toutes les cinq minutes parce que de
toute manière la redevance télé moi je
le dis je vois pas comment les français
sont pas en capacité de pouvoir
augmenter afin de supporter une
augmentation de la redevance télé
considère déjà aujourd'hui qu'elle est
déjà excessive parce que tout simplement
contrairement aux autres et matane
d'orange de canal+ où tout canalsat ou
ce sont des abonnements
quand vous en avais plus envie vous vous
désabonner donc le financement n'est pas
la même et pas perçu de la même manière
puisque dans la redevance télé
l'abonnement vous désabonner pas de la
redevance télé et tant mieux pour le
service public donc si on veut que
justement que ça dure moi je crois que
c'est sur le fond qu'il faut regarder
les choses c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
et dans l'étude qui a été fait ce qui
est intéressant de ce matin mais qui
était que claire qui finalement se sont
quand même plutôt les clubs de troisième
âge voire quatrième âge qui sont plus
aujourd'hui qu'ils regardent plus
franchement en france télévisions que la
jeunesse qui peut être aussi comment je
le dis peut-être que france télévisions
a des principes sur lesquels de temps en
temps il faut aussi s'adapter au monde
d'aujourd'hui la télé réalité ce sont
aussi des choses qui m'intéressent et je
le dis un public si on veut que ce
public ensuite viennent sur des
émissions sur la chaîne publique qui
peuvent être des émissions culturelles
d'information je le dis cette importante
n'est pas les éloigner donné les
palissades ne pas les laisser le besoin
pour un possible parce qu'ils ne
reviendront plus est déjà ça va être
très compliqué pour france télévisions
de les faire venir et je crains que vous
ne puissiez plus si vous n'apportez pas
je me dis comme je le pense et comme je
le vois je suis maman de quatre enfants
un de 24 ans le dernier à sept ans donc
je vois bien quand même
les différents programmes ils sont pas
loin les uns des autres ça montre bien
quand même que et c'est vrai qu'ils vont
jamais vers les chaînes
du service public et c'est pas faute de
sénou plus les adultes qui le faisons
que donc il ya besoin là de france que
france télévisions se se penchera dessus
sur les sur l'émission excusez moi mais
je pense que puisque vous êtes là peut
pas non plus ne pas en parler ou alors
ce serait hypocrite
voilà sans parler effectivement de la
liberté d'information
mais je crois que c'est sur la forme que
ça pose problème peut pas s'appeler le
service public
et moi qui croyais moi au niveau des
médias je fais quand même pas mal j'ai
jamais vu je le dis et médias interrogé
de la sorte jamais voilà donc il ya
peut-être sur la forme des choses à voir
et c'est ça n'enlève en rien votre
liberté
mais justement pour que votre liberté et
pour que ce soit pas quelque chose qui
soit complètement à charge parce que la
liberté c'est aussi la liberté aux
autres de pouvoir s'exprimer de se
défendre bien merci madame galy je passe
la parole maintenant à monsieur ça va
pour le groupe merci madame la
présidente de de réflexion vous avez
parlé monsieur président de grand nombre
d'objectifs qui vous était fixé 70 buts
60 des objectifs qui qui pose un
problème de dispersion et peut-être
manque de lisibilité
la question que je souhaiterais vous
poser c
bien entendu vous soyez vous souhaitez
que d'avoir beaucoup plus de souplesse
de mobilité dans l'organisation de
lisibilité de vos programmes qu'elle
serait à vos yeux les les quatre ou cinq
grands objectifs qui devrait être suivie
par france télévisions ou demandé à
france télévisions donc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous nous donne et quels sont à
vos yeux les c4 de cinq grands objectifs
deuxième remarque sur un volet qui
m'intéresse plus particulièrement sur le
sport j'ai été surpris et un peu déçu de
voir dimanche qu'une équipe de france
qui participe et finale d'un championnat
du monde de handball
ce match était retransmis sur une
télévision privée et que le service
public était une fois le plus absent
d'un grand événement sportif
alors pensez vous que dans les années
qui viennent
tous ces grands événements sportifs
seront aujourd'hui simplement réservé
aux chaînes payantes ou privés on le
voit déjà dans beaucoup de sports avec
l'augmentation bien sûr des droits de tv
ou peut-être que les chaînes publiques
ne sont pas en capacité de pouvoir
s'aligner dans les sols qui sont qui
sont proposés mais il ya d'autres sports
qui mériteraient je pense une audience
aussi bien en sport masculin que féminin
et france télévisions est assez absent a
les yeux de deux sur la retransmission
aussi bien sur des équipes de france qui
font d'excellents résultats alors on va
on va télévisée la finale parce que
parce que là tout le monde s'affole et
mais pendant un certain temps on est
complètement insensé vrai pour les
sports masculins comme pour le sport
féminin c'est assez regrettable
merci monsieur savin j'ai encore trois
demandes de prise de parole
blondin madame shiloh ainsi que madame
laborde et monsieur calvet qui
extérieures à notre commission mais qui
est bien sûr forte accueilli aujourd'hui
les sept que ouverte à tous je repose
poignets d'abord aux représentants des
groupes qui se sont exprimés et puis on
voit là on prendra les dernières
questions alors bien volontiers this
toutes ces questions sont évidemment
importantes
monsieur assouline évidemment je parle
d'ailleurs pas de rajeunissement mais je
perds je parlerai d'élargissement c'est
à dire que la mission du service public
c'est de toucher toutes les populations
vous avez mille fois raison mais toutes
les populations ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut plus touchées les personnes âgées
parce que rajeunir ça voudrait dire je
décale non il faut que nous continuons à
jouer ce rôle là mais il faut aussi
parallèlement que nous touchions les
plus jeunes
la question aujourd'hui du delà de la
pensée de la consommation des médias par
les jeunes ne touche pas que la
télévision elle touche tous les médias
c'est vrai pour la presse écrite c'est
vrai pour la radio c'est vrai pour la
télévision et c'est vrai pour les
télévisions les grandes télévisions
généralistes parce que les grandes
télévisions privées ont aussi une
moyenne d'âge plus élevée que la moyenne
de la population
donc ce point est un point qui est
extrêmement important il nécessite pour
nous très clairement que nous puissions
faire évoluer un certain nombre de
contenus qui intéresse davantage ces
jeunes alors gagner le point est central
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui disons le les
jeunes adultes ils ont globalement les
18 25 ans ils vont aller voir sur un
certain nombre de chaînes de la tnt en
fin d'après-midi de la télé réalité que
nous n'avons pas parce que là dessus
ce sont des principes je dirais
d'antenne que nous ne
ne développeront pas parce que c'est un
manque de respect enfin bon je vais pas
je veux pas le détail ici mais vous
voyez de ce que je vais évoquer donc
nous n'utiliserons pas les mêmes moyens
il faut que nous trouvions donc des
thèmes d écriture des façons de faire
qui nous permettent de toucher ces
jeunes alors c'est ce que nous essayons
de faire sur france 4 avec un certain
nombre de choses et en fiction et et en
émissions de découverte de métiers des
changes de débats où nous commençons à
voir des jeunes peu à peu mais c'est
vrai aussi sur tout ce qui est les
nouveaux médias faut vous sachiez que là
les programmes qu'on a sur le numérique
sous toutes les formes
un culturels etc plus de la moitié de
nos auditeurs sur ce numérique ont moins
de 50 ans c'est très intéressant parce
que c'est pas le cas pour le linéaire et
c'est très intéressant aussi parce que
la moyenne de la consommation du
numérique en france est plus âgé que ce
que nous avons nous sur le numérique ce
qui veut dire que globalement la
population plus jeunes regardent
davantage proportionnellement le
numérique chez nous qu'ils ne regardent
le linéaire ça c'est un point
extrêmement important
c'est vrai aussi sur un certain nombre
de programmes de rattrapage où on voit
aujourd'hui que les jeunes regardent
davantage le rattrapage que les plus
âgés mais c'est aussi et je reviens sur
d'autres questions concernant les
objectifs et concernant la façon de
faire ça veut dire aussi que nous devons
probablement en terme d'écriture en
termes de type de programme est bien
elle est peut-être davantage vers des
écritures plus contemporaines aller vers
d'été des thématiques que nous utilisons
moins et qui pourront permettre
peut-être d'élargir mais en même temps
on va se retrouver face à ceux qui nous
juge et qui diront qu'à écouter tel ou
tel thème ou telle ou telle façon de
traiter c'est quand même pas très en
ligne avec ce que vers le service public
et on a eu quelques exemples récents sur
certaines émissions qui ont été
vertement critiquée alors qu'elle avait
justement pour objectif d'aller de nous
développer vers vers des populations
différentes mais cette question dudu de
l'élargissement et donc la façon de
toucher les jeunes est importante alors
pour autant sachez quand même que 80% de
la population française 80 % en cdi
compris les jeunes regardent au moins 15
minutes cédées regarde le service public
chaque semaine donc il faut pas croire
non plus que nous avons toute une partie
de la pollution qui ne regarde jamais le
service public 80 % ça veut dire qu'on
est à un niveau de fréquentation
hebdomadaire qui reste extrêmement
importantes concernant le lait décret
monsieur assouline
d'abord je le connais pas encore la
ministre on a parlé à biarritz un que
les diffuseurs et nous spécifiquement
ayons des droits c'est extrêmement
important et je le dis c'est le travail
du sénat qui a permis cela je suis
personnellement réservé sur le fait
d'interdire à l'eau diffuseurs et donc à
france télévisions la distribution
d'oeuvres à partir du moment où le
producteur a lui-même société
distribution j'étais plutôt pour le fait
de dire essayons de le faire en
transparence et en transparence ça veut
dire essayons de voir celui qui est le
meilleur
nous on a aujourd'hui une filiale
distribution qui commence notamment dans
le monde du numérique à être plus
efficaces on a un chiffre d'affaires qui
se développe
c'est dommage de dire a priori qu'elle
ne peut pas distribuer un certain nombre
d'oeuvres
la troisième chose c'est un peu
technique mais je le dis il faut
absolument que la part dépendante de la
capacité que nous avons à produire en
interne ou à produire en faisant des
associations soient plus importantes
aujourd'hui nous avons droit à 5% de
parts dépendantes
là où les chaînes privées sont à 20%
je dirai au minimum il faudrait laisser
aux services publics autant qu'un qu'au
privé concernant l'information oui
france télévisions devrait avoir une
chaîne d'information je le dis toutes
les grandes sociétés publiques ont une
chaîne d'information alors il faudrait
qu'on a une chaîne d'information
aujourd'hui nous n'en avons pas je le
regrette
nous développons fortement le numérique
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui france tv info
qui est notre site d'information est le
premier site en fréquentation dans le
monde de la télévision
il faudrait qu'on puisse développer une
offre d'information alors on a un projet
après un faux 2015 d'une chaîne d'infos
sur le numérique on l'a dit et sur la
télévision connectée
mais là dessus vous avez mille fois
raison c'est le rôle du service public
de développer une offre d'informations
qu'ils soient plus fortes concernant la
la publicité même galim je partage votre
avis le fait que nous puissions avoir
éventuellement à certains moments de la
publicité ne perturberaient pas les
programmes et en particulier sur un
point concernant le sport je le dis si
je prends la question du sport d'abord
sur la question du sport si nous n'avons
pas eu la finale de hand ball masculin
c'est parce que nous avons été battus
par tf1 qui a mis un prix plus élevé
nous avons mis les prix que nous
mettrons d'habitude le sénateur je suis
dans un budget qui est extrêmement
stricte ans qu'on finance je peux même
vous dire que nous avons mis plus dans
les enchères que ce que nous avions mis
précédemment parce qu'on pensait que
c'était important et on a été battus en
revanche dans la même enchères nous
avons mis un peu plus pour les finales
du handball féminin et demi finale du
hand ball filmé à qui se dérouleront en
fin d'année et nous les avons obtenus
nous avons obtenu pourquoi parce que
probablement que le privé n'a pas donc
france télévisions sera au rendez vous
de la finale du championnat du monde de
handball féminin et de la demi finale
si la france y est et nous avons été
battus pour des questions d'argent et je
peux vous dire que nous le regrettons
fortement parce que nous sommes monsieur
le sénateur le
nous avons 70 % du sport gratuit en
france et sur france télévisions vous
aurez ce week-end le rugby tournoi des
destinations vous avez le championnat du
monde d'athlétisme vous avez roland
garros ou à vélo photo ne veux pas vous
faire la liste mais l'impression vous
avez en disant qu on déserte le sport il
faut en revanche cela vous est mille
fois raison c'est que on a eu avant-hier
une très mauvaise nouvelle c'est que la
coupe davis que nous avons toujours a
été achetée mais pas en france a été
achetée mondialement par bing sport
moyennant quoi on été évacués alors
aujourd'hui ce que nous faisons c'est
que nous sommes en train de dire à la
fédération de tennis c'est quand même
anormal que la coupe davis qui est
l'équipe de france de tennis
historiquement il n'ya pas des phases en
clair nous sommes prêts à payer mais
laissez-nous des phases en clair alors
voilà la discussion est en cours mais
quand au niveau mondial
vous avez un acteur qui s'appelle la
fédération internationale de tennis qui
vend toute la coupe davis mondiale à un
acteur le service public français il est
marginalisé il nous est arrivé la même
chose pour la coupe d'europe de rugby
des clubs
nous avons été aussi sorti par une
chaîne payante et où je dois le dire
grâce à une pression nous avons fait sur
la fédération française de rugby et la
ligue
nous avons obtenu un match par semaine
que vous voyez actuellement et je
pourrais multiplier les exemples donc
oui c'est un vrai souci
mais pour revenir à la publicité je vous
le dis ici
donnez nous les moyens d'avoir un peu
plus d'argent et donc donnez nous les
moyens mais c'est une demande instante
que je fait d'avoir de la publicité à la
mi temps des matchs qu'est ce que ça
peut faire
g vendredi soir une match du tournoi des
six nations galles irlande qui me coûte
cher par ailleurs si j'avais de la
publicité à la mi-temps en quoi ça
perturbe la mission de service public
pas du tout mais si je peux avoir à la
mi temps de ce match vendredi soir où
hier soir nous avions lille psg coupe de
la ligue ça ne coûte assez cher
si j'avais pu à la mi temps de psg lille
hier soir mettre de la publicité ça ne
dérange personne en plus de ça pardon my
head la publicité sur le stade tout
autour donc le multiplicateur y voient
de la pub
si je peux avoir des spots publicitaires
à la mi temps des matches ça me permet
quand même d'avoir quelques ressources
supplémentaires donc simplement ça c'est
une question
dont nous parlons depuis maintenant deux
trois ans elle pourrait se concrétiser
concernant les grands objectifs sous les
les grands objectifs
ils sont d'abord des objectifs liés à la
création
c'est à dire que nous devons absolument
à voir et c'est dans nos missions
et ça il faut que le le contrat que nous
avons avec avec l'état notre actionnaire
soient claires il faut que nous ayons
des objectifs en termes de création
création originale création sous toutes
ses formes le dessin animé très
important en france le documentaire le
spectacle vivant ça sont des objectifs
importants faut que nous ayons des
objectifs importants en termes de
présence territoriale
on y reviendra peut-être tout à l'heure
il faut que nous ayons des objectifs
importants en termes d'information le
rôle de l'information dans le dans le
groupe en termes d'innovation ses
objectifs en termes d'innovation sont
extrêmement importantes pour la raison
convient d'évoquer toucher tous les
publics et nous ayons des objectifs
importants sur un certain nombre de
valeurs
vous parliez du sport féminin mais plus
généralement tout ce qui est le respect
de la diversité tout ce qui est le
respect de l'égalité hommes femmes tout
ce qui est constitutif de l' équilibre
de la société ça ce doit être les grands
objectifs stratégiques
après il faut laisser à l'entreprise la
manière dont sept dans ce mouvement
extrêmement importantes modifications
que nous vivons de s'adapter et de
trouver les solutions
madame laborde
merci madame la présidente oui juste
quelques mots parce que beaucoup de
choses ont été dites alors donc depuis
que j'ai levé la main bien sûr il ya eu
un certain nombre de questions
et de réponse bonjour viendrait juste
sur le informez moi la notion d'un fort
mais je reviendrai juste en disant quand
on informe à 200% à charge
ce n'est pas ma définition de
l'information il ya eu un certain nombre
de choses dites donc je n'en rajouterai
pas ce que je voulais juste dire c'est
il ya quand même beaucoup de questions
qui vont êtres qui sont récurrentes
par rapport donc aux sports par rapport
aux femmes donc je suis ravi d'apprendre
que le handball féminin sera retransmis
donc sur la chaîne publique c'est un
coup de chance ou vous voilà il faut en
profiter pleinement
je pense qu'il y a quand même encore des
problématiques sur les stéréotypes en
général ça il faut vraiment vraiment y
être attentif et donc je vous le demande
en mon nom est bien sûr au nom de la
délégation aux droits des femmes et je
voulais que vous insistiez un petit peu
puisque vous aviez l'air d'avoir
commencé ce sujet sur la présence
territoriale qui n'est pas égal je pense
sur tous les territoires
est ce que ça vient de chaque directeurs
régionaux s je ne sais pas voilà je
voudrais en savoir un petit peu plus que
j'ai vraiment l'impression qu'il ya une
grosse différence entre eux et faire
trois régions ici et ailleurs on va dire
ça comme ça
et pour le reste je crois que j'ai eu
toutes mes réponses merci
juste avant de passer la parole à mme
anne blondin je me permet de compléter
la dernière question de notre collègue
françoise laborde est ce que la réforme
territoriale le redécoupage
l'élargissement tout cas de nos régions
conduit france télévisions à réfléchir à
l'organisation ou la mutation de
l'organisation de la chaîne dites
régionales à savoir france 3 d'un
blondin je rebondis sur ce que vous
disiez madame la présidente
parce que la réforme territoriale qui
fait des plus grandes régions va
certainement avoir un impact sur l'offre
régionale que vous pouvez faire et je
reviendrai sur l'offre régionale
un petit peu après dans mon propos
je voudrais saluer l'objectif un des
objectifs essentiels que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est à savoir la
création la création originale le
spectacle vivant c'est un point que
notre commission
regarde avec beaucoup d'attention et il
nous devrons pour cela avoir aussi des
professionnels bien compétent très
formée et j'aurais voulu rebondir sur un
sujet également de notre commission à
savoir la place des intermittents
maintenant dans l'audiovisuel public
vous savez que notre commission s'est
beaucoup attaché à ce problème et à
plusieurs reprises dans le secteur de
l'audiovisuel interpellé à ce sujet bien
entendu vous aviez fait des avancées
mais il ya aussi ce risque de
basculement vers des sociétés sous
traitantes et qui ne fait que déplacer
déplacer le problème
j'aurais voulu vous interrogé aussi sur
la fusion des rédactions de france 2
france 3 et l'illustré illustrer ma
question
parent un exemple qui s'est déroulé le 7
janvier dernier entre pour
l'introduction d'un journal
d'information évidemment france 2
mentionne donc le drame qui s'est passé
et france 3 est bien mentionne
l'ouverture des soldes
évidemment est ce que la fusion de ces
deux rédactions a pour effet d'avoir des
des choix éditoriaux comme cela je
reviens sur les régionalisation qui ont
été évoqués un petit point tout d'abord
notre local notre station locale france
3 iroise qui est quand même une des
locales les plus regardées et bien a
encore pâti ce n'est pas la première
fois des vacances scolaires parce que et
il y a eu la suspension du journal
d'information quotidien en langue
bretonne et là ça fait énormément de
bruit dans le dans notre département et
ce n'est pas la première fois j'ai eu
l'occasion d'interroger monsieur dubois
là dessus est bon c'est peut-être une
question d'économie vous nous en direz
quelque chose tout à l'heure le on a
évoqué la réforme territoriale
je rappelle la mission de russie et ses
préconisations
sans doute est elle faite à un moment du
calendrier pas très je dirais pratique
entre guillemets parce que votre mission
enfin votre mandat allait s'achever
reprendre les préconisations qui ont été
faites dans cette mission était
peut-être difficile
toujours est il que des orientations
sont donnés et qui s'inscrivent avec qui
ont bien pris en compte
le pacte d'avenir en bretagne avec ce
développement d'une offre audiovisuelle
régionaliser qui étaient retenus dans
voilà pour l'audition de rémy pflimlin
le pdg de france télévisions si vous
souhaitez la revoir elle est disponible
en vod sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr tout de suite 24 orsenna
le journal